yeah welcome to 5-minute game let's play
a 44 change and see Oh God the Petroff
okay and I don't really know notice to
all let's play this line it's a
fashionable at the moment yeah i'm not
sure if a castle long now can he take on
a 2 we are sometimes like really can do
that I hope that's not one of those
positions hit it again okay guess he he
will play for long castles yeah he did
okay maybe I can provoke some some kind
of a weakness with a six obviously I'm
like a very solid in this position you
shouldn't have any any huge problems
yeah I can get the bishop am now I think
with my chief I think I'll do that it's
not much but at least you have something
yeah probably a form by what he can play
Bishop gphone okay I don't want this
immediate exchange okay yeah this is
really very dry chess but it's a Petroff
it's very hard to get something
something something really exciting on
the board one of those openings which
always if one if all players tell me
yeah you need to play for it's just more
interesting or whatever I always tell
them okay you really think the Petrov is
a cool opening okay it's not fair chest
can be can be boring sometimes okay i
play a form the idea being a bishop f2
to get get the roofs exchange I want to
want to try to play em for something
with the two bishops but without any
heavy pieces on the board and frankly
speaking I don't have any great idea
anyway in this position I can only trade
some stuff on the e-file and try to yes
somehow get something in this end game
okay let's exchange all this
yeah the pawn structure is completely
symmetrical so and so it's really
difficult to even yeah claim for some
sort of advantage with the bishops the
bishops are a really a profit from ya
non-symmetrical porn structures yeah he
forces the trade what can you do and
he's also attacking the g-tube on
probably intending to put a bishop on e4
even okay let's cover this and try to
centralize the King King all the way to
e3 probably it cannot play h4 I can
simply take it yeah this I expected now
no the seat tube porn is a slight
weakness and down I cannot move the King
further should I play g-form who don't
know rah oh yeah that's it it's not the
most exciting position ever but Sir I
don't want to want to draw yet in a in a
game on video um g-form just too risky
or anything ok let's try G for my play
Bishop f 3 l.n.a Bishop Bishop age three
rg4 I should have played Bishop b2
really there should be two would have
been better all right it's I'm too late
now so what now g5 okay maybe it's
gained some space therefore porn is a
possible weakness but if I want to play
for anything here I need to I need to
accept slight weakness push it to to
deform provoke g6 maybe I can provoke
you sexy mmm where so now you cannot
attack at four with not g6 since the Sun
okay
I am plate c 5 which is Sam an
interesting move really what could I do
to improve the position i could try to
to get the bishop to f6 maybe I try this
not sure that I don't think you can play
d5 I can take ma 60 saying so okay so
maybe he wants to play 90 form possible
yar 94 is a bit a bitter bit awkward
really all right so I cannot really go
for Bishop detune yeah it's not much
happening here what what ideas do I have
maybe I still have some ideas still some
way our wait wait wait i can try to
activate this Bishop yr b to this could
be a possibility okay i need to have
this covered time money yeah yeah I mean
it's clear that's it is a drawer really
right but i want to i want to try a bit
maybe I'm overstepping the mark here
okay I don't really mind that it is it's
opened up even more so yeah this one's
upon what maybe you can go 94 but I
would get a six now think our 94
Joe and follow up for not much really
yeah and now I want to see what you're
moving do you want to Sutekh tender lamb
resigns yeah paid off to be a a bit
persistent here d5 was just bad I think
at least be at least this but but this
this now I mean I don't know this should
be a little bit of something it's opened
up and I know my idea was Bishop Bishop
to I to be too and where did you go him
idea was Bishop here Bishop here and
then trying to tickle him with Bishop d8
of course it's covered but this was just
one step to activate the position and
then maybe try try on for more maybe c3
b4 b5 and so on it's probably just just
a joy if you defend this correctly but
it's a yeah it's a bit cynical to play
in this fashion with black you will
absolutely never win against decent
player you can can only try to hold the
position yeah but didn't start working
all the time so as we as we saw him yeah
thanks for watching